yeah and for better or worse there's
minimal break time between these two
games so they're thrown right back into
the thick of the action fua needs to
recover at a moment's notice Magnus
feeling a lot more comfortable you can
see it on the camera he's uh back in the
zone and it's the Italian game Robert I
can confirm I did have some pasta for
dinner last night inspired by all of
those Italians we saw and uh wow what do
you make of this opening Choice bring
the bishop out early to G5 in a must-win
situation I think it's a good call from
alira and a better call from Magnus not
pushing his G Pawn as is the case in
many italian games when your opponent
brings the dark score Bishop out with a
pin so instead Magnus he brought his
Bishop to C5 then back to E7 he wastes a
turn so to speak but it's to keep the
foundation of his position solid do not
give Ali Risa the type of aggressive
play that he so desperately
desires yeah Magnus just trying to lock
things down we mentioned he will try to
suck the life out of this this position
he won't want to allow it to explode uh
to become fun but fua he has this
uncanny Knack of making positions
exciting later on making them really
complicated sometimes it backfires on
him we've seen that in that previous
game but fua if he can somehow make it
happen when Magnus least expects it he
does stand a chance right now Rook to E1
feels like fu is in preparation look at
the clock times Magnus pushes a pawn
he's next going to move the king out of
the ey line of the white light Square
bishop and it might be on the king side
here Robert fuja needs to strike and
soon in the center as you said the
Knight can jump out to H5 to put some
pressure on this bishop on G3 so the
idea is clear now from Magnus and he was
a bit lacking in space in particular his
Bishop on E7 that's staring into its own
pieces so he is trying to create new
avenues for the rest of his pieces I
love the move G6 it's a very smart play
now for ala do you continue with natural
development Knight C3 maybe even Knight
to D5 if the black knight ever moves or
do you save your Bishop David with A
Move Like H3 it's a bit calmer it's
quieter but it does keep the game going
in a way that Al Isa may want yeah I
like Pawn to H3 creating a nice uh
Escape Square for that Bishop on H2 also
preventing one of Black's main ideas if
white breaks out in the center I would
love to play Pawn to D4 open the middle
of the board uh control the middle of
the board potentially but Pawn to D4
here might run into Bishop to G for
pinning and at least causing some
discomfort for white so Point H3 a
multi-purpose move you call it Robert on
the board now and uh Magnus he might not
have time to play on the king side with
his F Pawn he plays Rook to E8 a bit
inconsistent but he's trying to get
ready for the white D4 Pawn push which
looks imminent might even happen now on
this next turn and uh Bishop to f8 very
passive viewers at home might be
wondering you know the freestyle
challenge the freestyle goat challenge
starts in a couple of days why is he
putting all his pieces back on the back
rank but Magnus just trying to get
organized he's trying to improve the
scope of his
rook and the bishop the bishop will come
to G7 where if D4 is played it will have
a longer diagonal to work with this was
the cost of Magnus Carlson's opening it
wasn't just time it was shutting the
door on activity for the dark Square
bishop and this bishop on C8 we
typically tell you not to move the same
piece multiple times this dark Square
Bishop has moved three times the bishop
on8 hasn't moved at all eventually it
can go to a square like E6 but there's
no rush for it because uh that Bishop
it's future is not evident a bishop E6
doesn't want to sit there does it want
to uh sit on D7 a little bit more
quietly these questions are not easy to
answer so Magnus punts on the decision
for now yeah and uh look at the clock
time as well already it's still early
days both players in preparation until
recently but fuja just looks like the
slower player right now maybe in his own
head a bit too much thinking about the
match situation Bishop to H4 though
Robert that is the definition of
provocation he's trying to pin he's
trying to force Magnus to lash out with
a move like G5 but um that's never going
to happen Magnus is never going to open
up his King in a situation he just needs
a draw Bishop back on G7 now looks
really solid for black how to break this
formation it's not
easy I like the idea from Ali Raza as
you said he's trying to provoke G5
Magnus wants no part of that he does not
want to push Pawns in front of his own
King he wants to ensure its safety so
what next that is a huge question in
order uh to start going for ideas and
trying to take advantage of squares he
need to move pawns create Pawn breaks
and open up files but a move like D4 is
now the right time now the black Bishop
is sitting on G7 it looks difficult to
accomplish and that's why we see the
Knight into D5 so David black is
responding Magnus all of his moves
they're logical follow-ups to White's
choices yeah really logical moves from
Magnus just improving pieces but finally
I think he might have to answer the
question what next this last move Pawn
to C3 indicates that white has covered
pretty much every Square on his first
four ranks Queen to B3 was in the air
hitting on the queen side Magnus trades
off Robert and this is a really
committal decision Black's light squar
Bishop was one of the pride and joys of
his position covering all the light
squares uh we talk about the Italian
opening the Spanish opening white light
Square Bishop as well on his side the
pride and joy and now it's uncontested
this piece to my eyes this looks like a
favorable trade for white do you think
Magnus has something specific up uh kind
of in store for
us well he pushed his G Pawn that's not
something he wanted to do but it allowed
him to get that light squ Bishop back so
Black's Pawn structure on the queen side
is doubled isolated A5 Pawn that could
be a Target later on and you've pressed
forward on the king side but magnus's
claim David is that his King is safe and
sound because there are no white
attackers in front of it so is this Pawn
A5 a weakness I would say absolutely but
difficult to get to it takes a night
journey to reroute and get there I like
White's position I have to admit but I
think that Magnus he's not unhappy to be
here yeah Magnus has advantages of his
own including this really strong black
knight now sitting on F4 and uh will he
score that's the big question the Black
Knight now solidify
and fja desperately trying to undermine
it if black now captures in the center
Pawn takes D4 I think alare here he
would leap on the opportunity of
removing that black knight from the
board with his Bishop forcing black to
break the pawn chain really ugly
structure there so I don't think Magnus
is going to get Hasty he want will want
to keep the tension instead but this
one's building Robert it feels like it's
uh really starting to come to life the
real fireworks in the near future but
but uh right now there's enough
imbalance there's enough hope for FIA
and uh yeah I'm liking what he's doing
he's at least got a position he's got a
game and he's alive in this
final and Black's Pawn structure is not
getting any better any time soon in fact
if white takes on E5 and black takes
back we see double isolated C Pawns in
addition to the IED a pawn but Magnus he
is counting on activity and play against
the white king and he does have the
long-term advantages so David I would
say that as this game continues the
advantage is in Ali raz's favor just
because of the pawn structure but the
dynamic play is in magnus's favor yeah
Robert I'm going to ask you to do one of
your favorite things to move some pawns
uh to squares that Unfortunately they
cannot go to if a black pawn were on B6
instead of C6 uh if Black's Pawn were on
G6 instead of G5 then Black's structure
would be perfect so harmonious no double
pawns isolated pawns no weak squares in
your camp but now the F5 square is a
huge Target for the White Knight to get
into later the black queens side pawns
just right for the picking in any end
game uh any end game actually White's
simply going to win you can create a
pass point on demand on the a file so
Magnus he won't be able to rely on his
endgame trickery anytime soon definitely
long-term Advantage wipe and I like the
fact FIA has sped up in what is his
second uh Champions chest or final 6
minutes on the clock against seven
that's closer than it has been for a
while
so um definitely shaping up nicely what
do you think Robert I'm going to ask you
now put you on the spot will we see
Armageddon
today it's funny because I was about to
ask you a question I was going to say
doesn't it feel like magnus's position
is more of Ali raz's alley Where Al R's
position is more Magnus style so in
regards to the Armageddon I actually
think it's quite likely just because
Magnus only needing a draw may have to
play forcefully and that's not
comfortable when you want to play Solly
to try to get that half
Point yeah Magnus will not be feeling
comfortable in this situation I've known
Magnus a long time and he really
dislikes it when longterm he's suffering
when he has these ugly pawns and needs
to compensate by showing real uh kind of
energy and uh to kind of gamble in away
and he is trying to gamble now Bishop to
C5 Robert given a question mark it drops
a pawn it's a big sacrifice a committal
sacrifice Knight takes A5 is available
for white is greed good here does fua
jump in and just call that bluff I guess
he's got to be worried about his King
side but does Magnus have anything
concrete against the white king I must
confess I don't see it I don't see any
justification surely if he wants to win
this match there we go he does get
greedy he snaps off the pawn and Magnus
goes in G for Glory Will he win this
game what do you make of this can white
fend off the
attack I think that Al is just in time
we talk about hooks that G4 push if
there was something attacked on F3 would
have pride open the white king side but
for now everything is under control H4
is a good move if black had a queen on
G6 already then G3 becomes a deadly
threat thanks to Bishop on C5 but that
seems quite a ways away and white will
see it coming Slide the king to the
corner and then maybe even move the
bishop out to H G3 not now Bishop G3
would simply blender a piece but in the
future the move uh Bishop to G3 if the
king is on H1 seems to have White's
position looking safe and sound yeah
King to H1 one of the first moves you
mentioned then a bishop on G3 looks like
an unassailable Fortress and uh one
that's actually cropped off in a lot of
classic games throughout chess history
um especially if white puts a bishop on
G3 and that Bishop's captured by the
Black Knight that pawn shelter that pawn
formation of Pawns on G2 G3 H4 just no
way through White's King will live A
Thousand Years uh in the corner uh kind
of on the H2 Square so Fu I think he's
doing everything right I think
Armageddon is a big favorite in this one
Magnus does need some real magic in
order to save this game I don't see it
white is simply going to come back with
the Knight to C4 start pushing the a
pawn or the B Pawn full control Queen G3
uh Queen F6 I was going to say met by
Bishop G3 guarding everything and this
Pawn formation wow Robert I must admit I
missed this one but Magnus allowing an
end game despite how bad the black pawns
are
counterintuitive to trade Queens when
you're down material all of our coaches
taught us if you're trailing you want
more pieces on the board because end
games will not be favorable but Magnus
spots that the pawn structure May
collapse very quickly with a bishop on
F2 also hitting this Rook on E1 so very
clever attempt from Magnus and Aliva
says I'm Not Afraid let's go outside
past pawns usually Rule the Day in the
end game he brings his Rook behind the
beat pawn it gets a question mark I I am
ridding us of that question that is a
good decision I think alizza is fully in
charge yeah he is dominating this game
we said it earlier any endgame favors
white due to the power of the past porn
the white a porn is likely to win this
game and I'm going to call it ala the
awn it's going to start sprinting
forward very very shortly Magnus though
what's he pausing about surely he has to
snap off the pole on G3 before it
disappears before the white king steps
forward and defends it um he's a porn
down after all the C6 Pawn is collapsing
look at those accuracy levels fua
playing one of the games of his life so
important here and he's playing so well
Robert so strongly and Magnus okay
desperately trying to mix it pawn to F5
we see the eval bar not approving not
liking this move but he's desperately
trying at least a source of counterplay
a source of light at the end of the
tunnel for the black ewn is there a way
to stop it running that's the big
question looks difficult to stop if the
pawn captures on F5 which seems to be a
natural try there it goes the bishop on
F2 helps it out as you just rush the ewn
up the board with the Rook behind it for
good measure so Ali rer right now he
sees how dangerous the position is David
can he just grab this C6 Pawn with his
Knight and then work around what will be
an annoying E Pawn passer that black
will try to turn into a queen I think he
can I think ala could get away with it
but that would as you mentioned allow
counterplay the move I would want to
play here if it works if it if you can
calculate is Rook to F1 just to try and
take the black F5 Pawn with your Rook
kill the counterplay before it even
begins kill it at source and uh if you
can somehow kick the black Bishop out
the way take that pawn you're just
loving life black has no passes black
can basically resign the only
complication is the fact that black
might be able to play a move like Bishop
to B6 hitting the White Knight you have
to work out that it all kind of H falls
into place um I don't see any reason not
to though Robert Bishop B6 I think you
can just meet with Knight takes C6 in
that position we're spitting out some
variations but this is all that's going
through Fu's mind he does not want to
allow Magnus a glimmer of hope I'm
predicting Rook F1 I think that's what
he's trying to work out he does not uh
By Nature want to allow any activity oh
wow he just plays B4
instead and that move I actually think
deserves the question mark your Rook F1
idea is well taken it would have
prevented black from getting this pass
pawn and F takes E4 certainly looks like
a nice try Bishop takes g3 at any moment
is going to potentially win the H4 Pawn
but David this position they don't have
the evaluation bar by their side they're
going on their own Magnus doesn't know
that he suddenly has an opportunity
because you play a move like Pawn takes
E4 I think that Al is just going to take
this Pawn C6 pushes B push pushes a
pawns and those are hard to stop as well
yeah still super difficult for black um
as you say Robert correctly the eval bar
is not available for the players so they
know the momentum the trend of the game
it's all been about white Alara is the
one who's made things happen who's got
the long-term advantages Magnus is in
Hustle mode and uh there we go what a
move really classy move there from
Magnus Carson the white E Pawn it's not
running away anytime soon Black's E5
Pawn is the one uh that he wants to push
down the board but it needs support from
the black Rooks and this black Rook that
he just moved was about to get kind of
semi- Trapped now it's going to Spring
Forward first Gaines time against the
White Knight which is defended and now
two pass pawns double pawns all over the
shot Robert who's are more
dangerous I would be thinking Rook to B4
just to go after these pawns on the
fourth rank but that E Pawn is the one
you need to stop and of course black
will push it forward and then again and
then one last time before it becomes a
queen so I would be super nervous here
if I were ala fuia the evaluation bar is
at zeros neither player knows that but I
would say more than anything it's become
a game with all three results on the
table it looked like one-sided traffic
now Ali Raza f is probably worried about
how he continues because the E3 E2 E1
push is so obvious yeah Magnus Carson
I'm going to eat my words I thought he
was almost out of it I thought he was
void of any active counterplay
whatsoever but Pawn to F5 that was just
pure genius uh just giving him practical
chances and suddenly you can see it on
the camera visibly fu is nervous he
realizes it's no longer within his grasp
necessarily he still needs to play
really well and uh just defend off
Black's active play he's given the
opponent a clear-cut plan and uh that is
the cardinal sin of Rapid chess 1 minute
30 against 4 minutes suddenly it's an
uphill struggle Armageddon it's a
distant dream Rook to B4 I love it
Robert he plays it ala he is going for
those black porns those weak pawns and
uh he's going to at least be able to
stop from behind the 4Runner the black
E4 Pawn if it steps forward but uh where
does Magnus now see counterplay it feels
like it's just a totally irrational end
game really hard to EV
it irrational is a good word not maybe
NE in life but for this position because
Rook takes G4 is check White currently
has six pawns black has five it's
actually hard to count them because you
see that they are all scattered they're
mostly isolated and after Rook takes G4
black will be a pawn down so I would
take this Pawn on G4 and then try to
bring my Rook back to E4 to freeze
Black's pawns before they run forward
this is looking like a position where
Magnus needs to prove that he can hold
the half point and whoa as soon as I say
that the wrong move from Ali Raza and
the blue arrow is in David Rook D2 and
Magnus isn't just okay apparently he's
winning wow Alara missing the
opportunity to grab a pawn for free with
Czech I'm not so sure about that one he
maybe was afraid of taking that pawn and
allowing the black king closer towards
the center but of course Magnus jumps on
that opportunity he finds the move
indicated by the blue arrow exclamation
point E2 is coming followed by Rook to
D1 check
and you're Landing you're touching down
that black porn is going to become a new
Queen it's coronation day almost not
just for the king Magnus Carson but for
that ewn allera he lost control he
allowed too much counterplay and
suddenly hard to even find a move Robert
it's inevitable you can't stop Black's
plan and I wonder what the difference
was because a turn ago it was all zeros
and Rook takes G4 that you could have
stolen a pawn I don't know why that
would have changed the nature of this
position Rook f one played Black can in
fact push the pawn to E2 you'll get this
Rook for a bishop and pawn I wouldn't
actually want that just yet can black
slow down David can black be extra
greedy protect this bishop first and
then push the pawn next Magnus does it
Magnus does it we saw that look on
magnus's face that kind of momentary
like that confusion that frown why not
why aren't I just winning right now and
I think it's starting to settle in it's
starting to kind of become real for both
players they Alla now down to 10 seconds
nothing he can do p E2 wins a whole Rook
this might be the last few moves of the
chestall Masters 2024 Pawn to E2 looks
automatic here Robert why not the black
Bishop's defended nothing to do ala
looked away 4 seconds left is this the
final moments of the
tournament it is Magnus Carlson he
needed a draw but he gets a win and you
can see that he is relieved he's happy
because Al of fuja gave him everything
he